[موسيقى]
من وشى بصدام حسين
الجانب الامريكي هذا الموضوع طبعا حساس
جدا والى تداعياته
انا يعني في اكثر اللقاءات التلفزيونيه
دائما احاول يعني هذا الموضوع اخذه
يعني اراده كما يعني انا ناقل فيه
الامريكان رورو روايتهم والرئيس ردا على
الروايه الامريكيه كتب رساله
حدود عملي كان ابلغ الرساله لمن عينيهم
الامر فقمنا بنشر الرساله وسائل الاعلام
وبلغت انه الرئيس الله يرحمه كتب هاي
رساله وحدد اشخاص معينين
[موسيقى]
لا اتمنى اي روايتين الشعب العراقي
واقرباء الرئيس وعائله الرئيس يعرفونه حقا
من الذي وشاب الرئيس فاني من باب جبل
الشرع النفسي او جب الشك والشبهات عن نفسي
انقل الروايتين والشعب العراقي
والمعنيين هم اللي يحددون بس انا فهمت من
بعض المصادر انه
تخلخلت روايه الروايه التي كان يقتنع بها
الرئيس وذكرته بكتابك حضرتك بانه قيس
النامق واخوانهم الذين وشوا به هذا مو انا
اللي ذكرته برساله انه هو هو اللي قال حدد
الاسماء بس انا بالمجمل الاحداث ما اتبنى
اي من روايتين هاي روايه الرئيس والشعب
يقيمها والمعنينه يقيمونها وهاي روايه
الامريكان وهم ايضا ولكن بالتاكيد في
روايات اخرى عن اشخاص اخرين قد يكونوا هم
من فعلوها
يعني هذا الامر متروك القادم السنين او
قادم الاشهر او قادم الايام
وللمعنيين الحقيقيين هم اللي يقدرون بهذا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]